[Music]
so today i'm afraid that we must cancel
vice president camille harris for i am
told the third time
i confess that i am reluctant to issue
this cancellation today especially after
jen pasake just yesterday raised the
issue of greedy meat conglomerates as
she explained big meat is responsible
for much of the inflation that we're
seeing at the grocery store and joe
biden fortunately has camila harris to
tackle that problem which is good
because we know that she can handle big
meat but even so despite how useful she
might be i have to cancel her
and i'm canceling her for this speech
which she gave during a holiday
fundraiser for the dnc it's extremely
shocking
objectionable
but take a listen
we must make it clear
democrats stand for workers rights we
stand for women's rights and we believe
that the right of a woman to make a
decision about her own body is
non-negotiable
non-negotiable
[Applause]
democrats stand for voting rights
and we are fighting and we will continue
to fight to pass the freedom to vote act
and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
[Applause]
we stand for dreamers we stand for farm
workers we stand for our lgbtq plus
brothers and sisters we stand for people
with disabilities we stand for our
children and the planet they will
inherit
now you might listen to that and think
that we accidentally elected a liberal
fortune cookie as vice president indeed
you might say that camilla harris is
speaking in the ancient and sacred
language of the bumper sticker but there
is something far more sinister going on
here i think
first of all let's go through this
quite shockingly
camila harris twice mentions workers she
says we stand for workers
workers rights farm workers rights
this is elitism and classism
as it excludes those americans who do
not work and have never worked and do
not plan on ever working
this is the democrat party's most loyal
and important constituency and kamela
hairs has simply erased them from
existence in this speech
she didn't even bother to mention the
rights of non-workers
she's pretending they don't exist
even though they are the ones who put
the democrats in power to begin with as
if that was not bad enough next the vice
president says that we stand for women's
rights and the rights of women to make
decisions about their own bodies
but obviously what about the millions of
men who become pregnant every year do
they not have rights over their bodies
should we force all of these
distinguished pregnant pregnant
gentlemen in the country to remain
pregnant against their will
apparently a man's uterus is public
property according to the vice president
to make matters worse camelo harris
talks about our lgbtq plus brothers and
sisters
now we're going to try to leave aside
the fact that the full initialism is
lgbtqip2saa
now i know that may sound like the kind
of random assortment of letters and
numbers that you might use as a password
for your gmail account and then
immediately forget the next time you
have to sign in but it's not
that is indeed the full acronym and yet
harris waves away
the qip2 saa members of the community
and expects them to make do with oh
you're the plus
all of those unique and distinct and
vibrant identities have been reduced to
a mere plus sign by camilla harris
the p's pansexuals the two s's two
spirits the aas alcoholics anonymous all
of these marginalized people have been
further marginalized by this exclusion
remember something silence is violence
and if that was not bad enough
she actually has the gall to speak of
lgbtq
brothers and sisters
this kind of gendered language has no
place in a progressive society sure some
members of the community may identify
with the binary concepts of brother and
sister but many exist outside of that
framework entirely
the more gender-neutral and thus
inclusive phrase would have been
lgbtqip2saa siblings
or even better lgbtqip2saa
individuals of indeterminate gender
gender with whom we share a common
affection traditionally associated with
the sibling relationship
is that so hard to say
well it was a little bit hard to say
actually finally in her most appalling
act of rhetorical brutality she actually
says
she actually says we stand
for people with disabilities
we stand
well there are some members of the
disabled community who cannot stand
in fact we stand as ableist and
exclusionary language we do not all
stand we cannot all stand and there are
those who can who can theoretically
stand and even walk but rarely choose to
like brian stelter for example
all of these people are valid and their
experiences are valid yet camille harris
deliberately chooses language which
fails to legitimize their lived
experiences
she may have thought she was being
inspiring in her speech but she used
words that were heteronormative ableist
racist sexist transphobic homophobic
elitist classes discriminatory prejudice
bigoted hateful and traumatizing
and i didn't even mention the fact that
the word dreamers was used
uh and has the effect of otherizing
those who identify as insomniacs
literally every phrase she uttered was
problematic
it's difficult to describe the full
emotional toll that her words have taken
on the most marginalized and vulnerable
members of our society
i don't know if they'll ever recover
camilla harris should be ashamed
and that is why today
she is canceled
for the third time
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content